how you doing I'm all right you listen
man I could not be more excited to see
your character in live action
um I really want to know what surprised
you about Dave's writing uh of the
character end of the entire series that
perhaps you weren't expecting
oh can I talk about that without
revealing anything I mean his writing is
very good it's very strong and all all
characters
um
uh you know have their own drive
and you you will probably
not
know
totally what's it all about until that
very last scene and I like that I like
that in writing that you take your you
know
you as an audience so seriously that you
can think for yourself that we that we
drag it right to the last moment to
reveal what what's the whole thing about
it yeah maybe I can't talk too much more
but I was going to say one of the things
about your character and the way he's
written in the books and uh and the way
he's been depicted is he's always the
smartest guy in the room and whatever
you think he's thinking he's five moves
ahead of you so what is it actually like
playing someone like that who is the
smartest one in the room that I mean
that's what you won as an actor yeah you
don't want to reveal everything you want
your secrets and uh when it's within the
script uh it's the best yeah because you
don't it's effortlessly effortless in
that sense you you cannot I mean you can
only play the moment then you don't
don't have to push anything because the
story writing is so good that'll tell it
for you so the first season I don't know
how many episodes it is it's eight to
ten no one will say I don't want to get
you in trouble but of those episodes
which one do you have a favorite episode
of the first season
I I don't think I can tell you
sure I'll move on to something my one
other thing
um what do you it's my last question
what do you think what surprised you
about making a Star Wars show that you
weren't expecting or what uh what do you
think fans would be surprised to learn
about the making of the show
well fans would have been surprised I
think I mean
um when you see the Jesus yeah it's it's
really epic in it I mean it's beautiful
and I think uh in terms of I I mean
it'll be baffling I think yeah and then
the story Rising which I think is very
strong so in that sense that would be
what is
that I mean what that you know what they
can expect
actually one last thing how long did it
take to do the makeup and what you to
get ready to step on set between two and
three hours yeah so I think we've got it
done to something to 22 30. it's all
right yeah it's because you I mean you
get into the character it's appearing in
front of you and you so it's for me we
had a DJ thing going I mean I sort of
pushed music from my own country to you
know to everybody in the band so it's
fun all I'm going to tell you is you
should totally do a cosplay at some
point and where where now that people
have seen it and wear the makeup out and
about because people will go
crazy yeah it could be fun couldn't it
I'm telling you you should really do it
and people will go crazy seeing you in
person thank you so much I can't wait to
see the show thank you